rich
it's a pleasure to speak with you just
want to let you know i got promoted
since our last chat
um so
good a man that's done some work there
are higher levels to achieve
to attain um so the three things i want
to talk about
is okay i got the book you recommended
the nice
uh no more mr nice guy okay there's a
thing when i was reading that book
i started to realize
i don't suffer from the nice guy
syndrome
okay um
but i still have an issue
with i think i'm good at
maintaining my frame but then allowing
the women to enter it
is where i kind of reach an impasse
there's something about that where where
are you screwing up
exactly
well i'm not sure i'm not sure i did
you know pass the first date certain
things i would do in my 20s i'm just not
going to do that anymore
okay you know it's part of my french
okay so what's your question for me here
but
well how do you maintain your frame
but then uh
make it inviting so that women actually
choose to enter it
so it's it's got to be something that
it's got to be attractive to her you
know what i'm saying like one of the
things that i get from
uh guys are like hey you know i'm um i'm
40 whatever
i don't want to date women my age i like
hotter younger women
how do i date hotter younger women and
it's like okay well you got to invite
her into your world right you can't put
on the justin bieber outfit and the
you know like the clothes that match her
generation you have to invite her into
your world
you have to give her something to get
excited about joining into that's kind
of what
you know um having her enter your frame
means is you have to
like have something there for her to to
get excited about i mean
um uh whenever i date women
you know like if they come over to my
house and they see the decor in the room
and they're like oh that's a nice couch
it's a
restoration hardware right i'm like yeah
they know that couch cost me close to
eight thousand dollars right
they see the car in the garage oh it's
300 000 mclaren cool right
so it's inviting right so
when i have to set a boundary or if i
have to put my foot down for example
i'm like hey you know this is a
non-negotiable
just do it sort of thing if they're
pushing back
um it's easier when
you've done it a few times it's easier
when you've got something that's of
interest to them
it's easier you know for them to enter
your frame when you have a frame that's
basically worth entering
you know if you know what i'm saying
well maybe i just don't have much to
offer
because like i i do a lot of fun
exciting things and i'm pretty fit
and you know but i don't so
so when we talk about entering a man's
frame it's it's
usually because you know in a
relationship
there's a little bit of a balance and
it's like you know are you going to
enter her frame
or is she going to enter your frame and
when you enter your
her frame it's because she's like hey
turtle you know i want to go to the
woofstock event this weekend with my
fluffy white dog with a sweater on it
and i want you to come and i want you to
hold my handbag and drive me there
and we're gonna walk around we're gonna
sit around with my friends for three
hours doing everything that i want like
that's entering her frame and doing what
she wants
right it's because you don't have
anything to offer beyond that
so you need to have something better
than what it is that she's trying to
offer you because women really
truthfully don't like it when a guy
enters their frame they
they hate um you know like little puppy
dogs that follow them around and
do and and say everything that they tell
them to it's like
you know she says jump and you're like
well how high do you want me to jump
sort of thing
um they really don't want that so you
have to give her something to
want to enter your frame on you know
she's going to want to follow the
boundaries that you set
so why so my question to you now is why
do you think that she's not doing that
like what are you missing um
i would prob to be honest probably game
okay
that's when i work in my game you know
like yeah again turtle
31 okay and i can't recall what we
talked about last time for the life of
me so
can you give me a little bit of frame
around what it was abroad it was uh
getting a better job
getting a better job okay so you got the
promotion yeah
what was the pay increase worth
percentage what
you know what it wasn't uh much at all
but
it was in a role that
i feel more suited to and
did you get a pay riser no yeah i did
yeah not much maybe like
a few hundred bucks but so percent so
percentage-wise like what are you saying
like less than two percent per paycheck
like 10 10 okay all right well 10 is not
too bad
okay but okay what i think it is
it's really hard for me to say this but
it might just be
i'm convinced that it might just be pure
smv
because i don't see myself as a beta i
identify
with the alpha okay and so
get you to switch on your camera or is
it too dark where you're at or like what
are you missing i want to take a look at
you bud
okay well you're not a bad looking guy
well you see
my thing is this okay the professional
women
you can date professional women right
um but they're probably going to be
lower smb
looks wise is what you're saying right
yeah
so that's kind of where i struggle
because
there is a balancing act of
you know the more professional she is
the more she's going to demand
and also not in addition to that sorry
my
classes are really jacked up but in
addition to that
i don't want to date too low on the
socioeconomic spectrum
because i just i don't find much
there like someone said earlier yeah
you're not a child
what's that so what you're saying is
that you're not attracted to her when
she's below you like that
well yeah because it's hard to i find it
hard to connect with them
with someone who is not as you know
intelligent
what do you do for a living again i do
business development okay and where do
you live like what
what part of the world roughly chicago
illinois
and your take-home pay last year was how
much
under last year was under 60 000. yeah
so i mean like you can't punch up too
high like you're not going to date a
lawyer you might
get yourself a paralegal i mean she
might date you but the paralegal is
going to be looking to date a lawyer
right
like i was talking to andrew before we
went live i think and he's like yeah i
date a lot of paralegals well it's easy
for him because he's a lawyer
right and she's a paralegal so she's
going to look up to him it's like a
security guard knows that he's not a cop
like a police officer knows that he's
better than a security guard a security
guard over
knows that he's further down the social
economic scale you're going to have a
hard time dating you know professional
women making
under 60 000 a year because professional
women like we're talking about in this
cast earlier like
lawyers doctors uh medical professionals
accountants like
in that sphere of things they're making
over six figures and because women are
hypergamous they don't want to date down
with men they want to date up they want
to be with a guy that they can look up
to that they see as a giant so
they're looking for you know kevin the
vp of sales or steve the vp of
accounting
right or the cfo of the new tech startup
sort of thing like that's what they're
looking for
that's what their expectations are
anyway right and on top of that you got
to be six feet tall and six
six-pack abs and six months out of a
relationship and a 600 horsepower car
they have 231 you know checklist and
they just finished reading
why men love so they're a little
bit disagreeable too sometimes
so right like i i wouldn't put that much
focus on chasing women which is really
you know
what i essentially you know concluded at
the end of my book who
conveniently you know also aaron cleary
you know concluded at the end of his
book you know the book of numbers the
roa on
chasing women is the roi is on yourself
don't worry about getting duck girls
the girls will come when you're worthy
of the girls you know sort of thing
um you know the next step for you is
okay making 60 grand last year got a 10
pay raise let's see if we can get that
number up to six figures 100 grand
right i don't know is there a side
hustle that you can you know
slap together you don't have any kids
that you're taking care of you don't
have a wife or an ex-wife or anything
like that right
right so it's getting on the grind i
mean you're a good-looking guy you got
some style you got a decent haircut you
know the beard looks nice and clean and
trim the glasses
you know fine you know you've got like
the optics
okay but i've said this before you know
women have a lot of patience for a young
chad like a 21 year old chad with a plan
they'll be all over him like a fat kid
on cake lots of women it's true okay
but if you're a 41 a 45 year old chad
and you don't have anything to show for
yourself but you might have a plan
they don't have a lot of patience for
that guy right and you're somewhere
between
that 21 year old and the 40-something
year old only
you probably want to get closer to 100
grand by this time
right all right and i'm not saying that
so you can get the girls like i'm saying
that so that you
as a man can be spoiled for choice you
can be the sexual selector you can say
you know what
rachel i don't like you i don't like
your attitude
don't let the door hit you on the way
out all right because becky's coming
over later on tonight
and she doesn't give me that crap you
know what
what you said is 100 true because when i
was in my 20s
i was able to do i was able to pull that
off right where
just as you said they're willing to
overlook you know
uh your height profession or whatever
because i don't know why but they're
just
willing to overlook but in my 30s it's
like they you gotta be
pristine so men must become
you must like men are made okay like
we have to make something out of
ourselves we can't rest on our laurels
um because hey you know i like
the um the guy earlier though that was a
teacher like you heard him right
yeah yeah so if he was like a chad
teacher
he'd have women no no problem but he's
an overweight teacher
right so like you know like have
have something going on here have as
much going on as you possibly can it
looks money status game right like those
are the main things if you're
insignificant become significant
if you're fat lose the weight you know
build some muscle broad shoulders narrow
waist
if you don't make enough money make some
bank right
you don't have any game because you're
awkward and you're anxious all the time
learn game right practice it make some
cold approaches buy a course you know
read on
how that works
you